Oh, Donny Doki three times in a row.
I'm tired.
That's really it.
I took a nap.
And here I am.
I'm Epidoki.
I just woke up.
I'm not okay right now.
My body is dying.
My body is like, what is this?
over.
Why did it come back?
I don't know.
So anyway, I'm here.
We're, we're good to have.
We're going to be waiting, uh, because I leave, uh, the
other girls are still a little busy right now.
So to pass the past the time we are going to play some
street fighter because the last time i played was a little
longer than it should have been so we're gonna pass some
time with some street fighter i was supposed to get a little
oh wait wait actually i could ask coaching right now when
was the last time was yesterday at 8 28 and wait was it
actually 8 21 1 a.m.
was yesterday.
Is that what yesterday means?
It is what yesterday means.
Street Fighter 6.
I'm going to drag my coach up right now to do some coaching.
Give me a sec.
I'm here.
He's in 2x here.
Are you awake right now?
Emergency coaching.
Alright.
Here we go.
all right it's for those who are wondering why is she
playing street fighting i have a tournament next week i also
have an overwatch tournament next week but i'm not
practicing that
all right that's not that's not prior prior right now my
priority is not get my ass kicked too hard
so I am a mess let's see I'm gonna make sure oh my gosh
where's my mouse why is my mouse not reacting all right all
right here I go okay I do need to here we go we still have a
collab we still have wait let me put on text for those who
don't read the chat um
body is so not used to being a woman anymore.
For those who have missed out on earlier today's stream and
new context, I haven't had my time of the year in seven
months, and now my body is re-experiencing womanhood.
Practicing street fighter tournament until girls are ready.
I swear to God, they're ready now.
Oh my God.
Okay, wait.
There we go.
I'll put that here.
I think people can read that.
It's a little tiny, but I'm pretty sure.
Oh, it's not supposed to be.
All right.
I'm ready.
It's okay.
All right.
Yes, I am now a fucking filthy my player.
Please do not judge.
Do not judge me.
I will stoop this low.
Yes, I will stoop this low to not get absolutely destroyed.
I...
Let's see, I got a stick.
Yes!
That's right.
I will be a filthy mob player.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
I am desperate.
I will still get my ass kicked.
But I am desperate.
I would like to know that my coach does not believe in me.
And therefore, he has a good reason.
He has a good reason to not believe in me.
Alright, guys.
Want to see me get absolutely destroyed right here?
First game.
Are you ready?
Oh, this guy's a two-game win streak, too.
Are you guys ready?
Oh.
Oh, stay down.
Oh, no, I stay down.
I stay down.
Oh, my God.
What do I do now?
Okay.
No!
All right, wait, wait, wait.
Give me a sec.
Oh, stay down.
There we go.
I was on the other side.
I forgot my moves when I'm on the other side.
Oh, stay down.
oh my oh shit she's gonna know my she's gonna know unless
that's right
oh oh shit she punishes me oh Oh, fuck.
I fucked up.
Now I fucked up.
No, she's doing shit.
Help.
Oh, shit.
It's okay.
It's all right.
I'm dead.
I see.
Oh, no.
Guys, this is my first game, guys.
Please.
Please be gentle.
This is my first game.
Oh.
Alright.
Get out of here.
Don't get close to me.
Oh my god.
Get away from me.
Get away from me!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Wait.
No!
You plugger!
There's no way.
Okay.
No, she won by fucking lagging, you bitch.
You bitch.
Oh my gosh, she, the fucking, of course.
You bitch, you actual bitch.
You bitch.
Oh my God, I hate her, I hate her.
Oh my gosh, she won by lag.
She won by lag.
She actually won by lag.
This whore.
Okay.
I could have won that too.
I got beaten so hard by lag.
Oh, no, not hate tomorrow matchup.
Oh, they're ready.
Last, last one.
Alright.
Oh, oh, shit.
I'm so bad at counter-DI.
Not fair.
Oh, my god!
Bitch!
Okay, I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
Oh, I should not have done that.
I should not have done that.
Okay.
What?
I...
Fucked it up.
No!
We both had the same idea.
Alright.
What?
Okay, I did that late.
Ah!
I'm so bad at counter drive!
Oh.
Oh my god.
Fuck.
It's alright.
I had to die anyway.
Guys, I chose to.
to die because they're ready for the collab guys.
Guys, I chose to die.
Guys, I chose this.
I chose this, guys.
I chose this.
Oh my god.
No.
It's okay.
I chose to die.
Guys, it was a choice.
It was a choice.
it was a fucking good choice guys it all right let's get
into a cop all right hello hello sorry i was trapped in the
i was trapped in the street fighter game sorry i was like
wasn't going street fighter streamer um i'm sorry although i
yesterday i saw you playing fields of mystery i'm like i'm
gonna wait new update comes out.
Nope.
I just started playing.
It's like Stardew Valley.
It's like Indy Stardew Valley.
It's so good.
How do you rate it against Stardew?
I actually don't like Stardew, but I like those memories so
much more.
I find Stardew Valley a little bit ugly and nobody's pretty
enough.
Nobody's pretty enough for me.
Okay, Dustin, go to bed.
We need to kind of pass into an Animal Crossing which kick
villages out for being like too visually unappealing pretty
much you can but you can install the mod and make it look
different video game with too many steps i was gonna say
you're asking i'm a leader and saw mods that's that might be
a little too much you okay just hey massey what do you like
about the game and well i i like fields of mystery but i
know walls yeah it's tough but um fields and mister is very
pretty oh man you look it up everybody's hot like everybody
is hot wait who are you romancing i haven't decided yet oh i
knew i knew instantly when i saw my wife who who are you
romancing you gotta be more specific than that juniper the
the bath house owner the sexy every season she has less and
less clothes on that's my wife God, could we please see
women as people?
Oh, yeah, it's like, please, please.
I want to go here.
I'm like, I'm no better than a man.
You know what?
No better than a man.
Oh, I guess when it's summertime, right?
That's where Oh, she's got a crazy bikini.
Oh, my God.
It's wild.
She knows what she wants, guys.
She knows exactly what she wants.
Well, it's glad to hear the kids are having fun.
Why not add a line?
She has pink hair like me, but then I was like, we can't be
two pink-haired people in a relationship.
Yeah, but then you have a baby that's pink hair, too.
It's not going to work.
But then I met Mark, and I'm like, oh, he's Sundaray.
And he hates me.
I kind of like that.
He's just playing hard to get, you know?
He's really...
Yeah, he's like playing hard to get.
I'm like, Sundaray, bro.
Oh, boy.
Oh, my God.
Soon, soon, soon.
I'm trying to get the...
What about...
I'm gonna love Juniper.
I love Juniper.
That's my wife.
She can be mean to me.
Wait, she said yes yet?
So, funnily enough, I didn't realize how to romance her
because she's a woman of taste.
And so, actually, during one of the first events, I
missed...
You have to, like, invite someone to, like, a festival
thingy.
And I went to go invite her, and she went, Oh, you're
serious?
And I was like, yeah!
She's like, oh, but now, but now I have her gold starred,
baby.
Now, now, now!
You're like, oh, you want me to come over?
Yeah, she was like, oh, oh, you're serious.
This is who she is.
She's pretty hot.
I'm showing you chat with her for the sake.
Wait, I'm gonna wait.
I'm just, I'm fixing her.
You know, sometimes when people are talking about video
games, I like to pretend that they're talking about like
real life situations instead.
And this is not a good look in that light.
Look, look.
This is because she told me to get lost and to leave her
alone like 17 times.
for sure baby that's her summer skin baby most people have
skin all year round only for summer you should you should
just download the model that's her skin throughout the year
that should Who's going to get hyposamia?
You don't want anyone to romance if you do that.
All right, wait, who's making the private room for us?
I can do it.
Don't worry, my children.
All right, let's time her.
Let's see how fast they'll take her.
Wait, I gotta open the game.
I said, do you guys play this game?
I haven't played this game, but I knew they had a beta.
one time but I it was like during the demo and I don't know
what the heck I was doing like there it's like you want it's
like play the tutorial I was like now we got this but we can
I don't believe in Lonnie we'll figure yeah we'll learn on
the job figure it out make it till you make it you know
that's what I said burgling what is it what's this game
called burgling no I'm not gonna put it I'm gonna make sure
I'm not at unlimited frames for this game oh yeah Mike only
in-game yeah yeah in-game mic do you want to use it do you
want to use in-game mic yes yeah yeah it's okay it's more
fun okay okay okay okay let me oh god uh okay private game
yeah i wonder if there's a mod where you can have more than
one girlfriend and boyfriend in the field of mystery oh
probably honestly if no but now you said it soon that will
be someone will make it make it please i am in the video i'm
in the video game too i'm in the video game me i'm on my
have mercy daddy account okay i see it i see it online i'm
bugging gnomes well i can join your game gnomes helicopter
yeah oh my god you just got you got spat out by this thing
oh my god hello wait you're in the mouth oh hey guys i'm in
already Gross, gross.
Emily invite the others.
I don't know how to invite them.
They have to join off of me.
Okay.
I'll self-invite myself.
Wait, I gotta turn down the sun.
Remy out.
Are you in here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You just gotta crawl out.
You're gonna join it.
You just do right click.
Oh, there you are!
Congratulations, it's a boy.
I'm on fire, I'm on fire, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
How are you?
How are you dead already?
give you cpr oh nope there you go i guess that's how it
works all right wait is it am i am i ready open mic aaron
all right let me mute myself all right hello all right but i
gotta adjust the volume for this game oh this thing is like
it's main is main volume voice chat well we'll find out uh
we'll see whoa you are so i just hear you blasting in my ear
just now hey hey hey i'm not i'm not a gnome i'm not a good
nom i'm not a good nom i'm a gnome and you've been No, you
punk.
Huh?
You get bin?
You know, he heard of that?
I'm not a good elf.
I'm not a good goblin.
I'm like, no.
Yes, you, bin.
I can hear you.
I'm going to turn off my hand.
Wait, there is.
Yeah.
Wow.
Wait, why do you have long eyes?
Oh, oh, my God.
Oh, I'm touching you.
I'm sorry, Rin.
Kid.
You won't be.
Sorry, get out of here!
Yeah, scram, shoot!
Oh my god, your arms are freaky!
Wait.
I'm...
Hey, big girl.
These gnomes are like a subspecies of spider or something,
like God.
Our ancestors were spiders.
I'm smacking you.
You, you, me when I get you, me when I get you!
How are you doing that?
Oh, God.
All right.
I don't know, guys, to my chat, is everybody's volumes okay?
Testing, testing, testing.
Testing, testing.
Oh, you know.
I thought that's the only thing we know how to do.
Can we touch it in the mouth?
If we go in there to like...
He's opening it.
Oh, dude.
No, he's not doing well.
He does not.
Do not touch him.
Oh my god.
He's closing his mouth.
Do not touch him.
No self-preservation instinct this one.
All right.
I think we're...
Oh boy.
I'm creation.
Yeah.
Oh wait, don't worry.
I know CPR.
Set yourselves on fire.
Don't worry.
I know CPR.
Wait.
Goodbye.
It's a real one today.
Oh boy.
Oh wait, I'm alive.
Look at that.
Oh shit.
my arm hello died oh my god wait do i slap my arm my arms oh
no my arms oh it's okay i can grow it's okay it's just a
flesh wound replaceable it's just yeah it's replaceable all
right let me adjust my volume a little bit more let me
probably one out of one yeah i know that's why i was so sad
when she couldn't make it to the escape room she
is the smartest of us all right well of creation what is
that more than oh we can buy stuff later i guess after we
rob people also if you guys get sick in video games there is
a uh there's emotion sickness i don't get sick i'm a gamer
escape and then go into settings it's under game make sure i
have that on and then you can turn down the mouse
sensitivity to like move your camera
That's okay.
It moves your mouse.
It makes your mouse less sensitive.
All right, you guys ready to start?
We don't know how to play this game.
But we're gonna start gnoming people.
Also, guys, I think my audio people...
Hello?
Hello, yeah.
Hello.
Oh, oh, there we go.
Goodbye.
Guys, I think my audio people...
are not alive today so any of my mods mods is your job for
sound check safe if someone's gonna have signed off on this
there we go we live we're alive all right all right mousy
since you have the most experience in this game you're our
leader you're a squad leader what do we do what did you
Yeah, I think we're supposed to kill the guy that lives in
that house.
Oh shit.
I'm down for that.
Oh, let's go We're gonna win this there's four of us and one
of him We got this We gotta kill him and yeah Let's go.
I I get the angles All right, let's go in Listen, we can
resurrect so ring that's like a trillion of us.
I got the door.
Is this push or pull guys?
Is this push or pull?
a house key that's out of interest oh we need a house key i
think wait there's a grab it's i don't know i just right
clicked you press the grab button there's a grab button wait
i can do the window window yeah i'm gonna go through the
window all right you can open the window you can open the
window no not you uh right click then left click yeah yeah
yeah all right i'm pretty sure we're supposed we're we're
burgling gnomes so we got i got coffee guys i got coffee
he's gonna be depressed now i'm bringing it home i feel like
we need to try and figure out how to open the door just for
the sake of having an escape route uh you know that you're
you're right i feel like unfortunately Wait, there were
stuff...
Ooh, what's that?
Guys, there's stuff here.
Alright, we're in.
Let's go rob this man's kitchen.
The presence of a dog bowl implies the presence of a dog in
the house.
It's alright.
Oh my god!
There's someone over there!
There's a man!
Hi!
Curious.
This is my cabinet!
Goodbye!
I didn't get it!
I'm trying!
We're the best!
All right.
Gnomes together, shrine.
I think she...
Wait, wait.
Oh, oh, oh, is he blind?
He might be blind.
He blind?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's okay, guys.
He's clinically stupid.
All right.
You don't know that.
He could be blind.
That's why he has a dog.
You might be.
What's the...
What's the flaw of this game?
We just...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Get in the cover!
Okay, I like how Massey did not want to stack with us.
She's like, I'm gonna get my own cabinet.
Yeah, yeah.
What are we doing?
No space.
What's the plot?
We're supposed to bring the items to the house.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, whoa, whoa.
You get it.
That's okay.
It's okay.
Yeah, reach it.
Get open.
We're okay.
No one's home.
Okay, we're supposed to steal a plunger, flush.
Gather gravel.
What?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's what Mousy said.
Oh, that's what I found.
Okay, I think he's gone.
What the hell do you mean?
Gather gravel.
Okay, he's gone.
He's gone.
Mousy, it's safe.
Like, he's gone and gone several times.
He's probably going to be back.
Oh, he's leaving.
Wait, where's Mousy?
Okay, I'm going to go.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, he's coming.
I let him to you.
I'm sorry.
That's all right.
It should be fine.
Watch out.
He's dumb.
Oh, he's dumb.
Thank God.
Yeah, he's pretty dumb.
I mean, he is old.
Time gets for all of us soon.
Oh, shit.
I think he saw me.
All right.
No one's home.
You think he knows?
I don't think he does.
I don't think he knows.
He's stupid.
Look at him.
That's why your kids don't visit you anymore.
Yeah.
Your wife left you, bro.
Yeah, bro.
All your kids don't want to see you.
They've been trying to put you in a home.
No one loves you.
No one ever loves you.
Yeah, the only reason why your dog loves you is because you
feed him.
Oh, shit, we have 10 minutes left.
Shit, we have 10 minutes.
Yeah, but I think he deserves it though, you know, it's it's
fine.
Oh, I found I got marble Oh, oh shit.
Oh shit.
What's he gonna do grab me?
Parkour Oh my god Oh, no
They got it They got it your horse I grew my legs back.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
That's cool It's okay.
It's okay, I'm right behind him.
All right.
Oh my God, oh my God, you-
Kitchen!
Get out of the kitchen!
Oh my God, they flushed you!
All right.
Okay, it's fine.
Oh wait, there's a Rumba.
How do I use my marble?
Oh my God.
Oh, whoa.
Whoa.
Okay.
Guys, get out of the kitchen!
What?
Travel.
Where am I?
Oh, fuck.
Oh, shit.
Oh, he's with my baby!
Still in the kitchen.
Oh my god.
He's got me too.
Wait.
He's infecting me.
I pay rent.
You can't infect me.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
Everything is fine.
I'll just squat is right.
But he's an idiot.
Okay.
Amali and Britt are still in the kitchen.
I don't know what they've been doing.
kitchen dude we got it's okay i'm i why are you guys still
in the kitchen
oh it's the window it's okay oh my god he closed the window
he closed the key i'm okay at least i didn't get flushed
like a I think I think they're actually just stuck in the
kitchen How did they like he locked them in I hear them Yeah
We're not tall enough to free them
We can carry them I believe I believe Oh my god he's back
Oh, oh, the doors are locked!
We did!
Oh, no, he's gonna hurt!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, I can save you!
Don't worry!
Get out!
Before it's too late!
No!
Oh, that caught me, dude.
Remember me as a hero!
Alright.
I'm back.
I like how every time he catches me and he just throws me
out, every time he catches Mousy, he fucking cooks her.
Oh, I'm sorry!
Oh, he's gonna cook me!
Where are they?
They leave the kitchen now!
Why?
Oh my god, someone please!
Oh, wait, Amelie's gonna be by sea.
I think he got one of them.
He got...
No, no.
Oh, it's ruin.
Ruin is out.
Freeze.
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
Amelie got the...
We're gonna be...
We're gonna be crispies like nuggets.
Oh, God.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
There's still five minutes.
What the...
It's okay.
So you...
Wait.
Yes!
No, we're both in here.
Save us!
Ah!
Save!
We're getting caught!
Please!
We don't deserve this!
We're like flopping like worms.
Look at us go.
Hey, at least...
at least... yeah?
You know, at least they're doing stuff now instead of being
in the kitchen, you know?
At least...
It's the little things.
It's probably for the best.
We'll be coming.
Oh my god.
Never mind.
We are no longer rescuing Doki.
They just said they weren't rescuing us.
Did you hear that?
Oh no.
I don't think they're coming back.
I don't think.
I'm getting smaller and smaller.
Am I losing my mom?
I literally, I spectated them and they're like, we're not
coming back for them.
We're dead, man.
Wait, are you dead?
Yeah, I'm dead, dead.
We're dead.
You guys break a window.
You didn't come back for us.
I'm gonna haunt.
You have to break a window.
I'm gonna haunt them.
Just throw at the window.
Yeah, I think I have to climb first.
I got it.
Don't worry.
I'm a carry.
I climb up here.
Where's Red?
I can get up.
here oh all right i believe yes jokes on use break the
window in break it hey oh that's what that old inspector in
my vision is it's me to see how you the ghost of your past
like quite i'm here to haught you you know what you did you
know what you did by definition nothing Who's that over
there?
What the fuck?
Yeah.
What the fuck is that?
I was about to say, thank goodness I don't think full
damage.
Telling you to fall about this one.
Oh, no, we're late.
Making my way downtown.
Crawling fast, crawling fast.
Now we go.
That's my...
I don't know any more than once in a song.
Oh, I know.
That's my 52nd high.
To pass on because of my beautiful voice.
Wait, they could just illegal.
You, my God.
Oh my God, she can't revive us.
Not yet, I give up.
Go back to the ball.
Go back to the ball and revive us.
I'm trying.
I don't care.
I wonder if anything.
Oh my God.
I gotta break a window.
Get a Roomba.
Go to the ball.
Go to the ball and revive us.
Go to the crystal ball!
We should revive?
Yeah, ball us.
Oh.
Go bother the arm!
Oh my god, we're back.
Oh, we're back.
Oh.
We do only have two minutes left.
So we definitely need to break some windows right now.
We have to break windows.
What is a gobble?
Gather grapple.
Grapple what is that?
Okay, so I mean we've already gathered some gravel, but I
had a gravel, but it but he got toasted What does it look
like Mousy?
What does it look like?
Could you identify what Grapple looks to us?
Yeah, what does it look like?
The one that I picked up looks like it's in here.
Is that the red?
Yeah, didn't they?
Oh Like marbles?
No, that's a marble the red one was the Okay, we gotta
figure out how to break the wood.
Oh, he's coming.
I'm gonna close the door on him Nah closing the door on him
if I can't see any doesn't exist.
I don't think that was that was a scrabble We are the loose
grablins.
I'm gonna go over here guys.
We split up gang Everything always works out when we split
up Maybe I'll find a grabble here All right Where the fuck
is a gravel?
Oh.
Ugh.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh.
Oh, is that somebody's credit card information?
Ugh.
How does one hardcore...
Out of time.
Let's get to the tornado.
Our Uber's here!
Guys, our Uber's here!
It's okay, we got enough.
Hurry, if we wait longer than five minutes, they charge us.
Oh, my God.
All right.
No!
Oh, I'm getting him in, I'm in, I'm in.
Wait, where's Mousy?
Where did she take the tornado?
I guess we'll never know.
I'll
enroll the nuns.
live my god understand now i was yeah no wait do not set
yourself on fire immediately off the landing where did mousy
go mousy mousy are you in here or did she just not make it
back to the tornado are you in here mousy mousy we gather
here today in memory of iron mouse he was good no she was a
really good you know oh there she is i i got my best yeah
Hey, what do we do with your respond?
No, I'm just trying to do that.
Oh, well, oh, we did gather gravel.
Wait, did you found gravel?
Oh, that's what gravel looks like.
Oh, gravel is like sticks and stones.
I'm done.
Sticks and stones mean, grab my bones.
Oh, because we have gravel, we have skrags, we have clunk,
we have plaster.
Oh, what did you upgrade?
Clunk, clunk, clunk.
Wait, what did you buy?
Oh.
Oh, no, it's the points that we made.
Oh, it's okay.
We've got our jobs.
Oh, it's like repo, but we're gnomes.
Yeah.
We're gnomes.
I mean, I guess we did, actually.
I guess these are our graves.
This is when we both died here.
I don't remember us.
I don't remember.
What spring shoes?
Can I make spring shoes?
In loving memory.
Yeah, you can.
Make it.
Yeah, that would help if I see with the climbing problem,
wouldn't it?
That would.
Oh, there she goes.
That old gloves.
No, we can't make glue gloves.
We don't have enough.
Yeah, we don't have enough.
Oh, we can go to the island.
All right.
Do we want an island or deep forest?
Where do you want to go?
We can also make a backpack.
Oh, that would be smart.
The island looks nice.
All right.
Close because it looks sunny.
Click the island.
Let's go.
Let's go to the beach.
beach let's go get away in game and judge are we starting
the let's go to the norm island boom let's go to the norm
island whose island is it though oh he's calling for us
put your hands in the air makes it feel like you're going
faster
To the island unrelated to all the other islands
Oh wait, this does look wait this looks good away.
Wait, I this does look like the island wait a minute Oh,
whoa.
Oh, you landed on the water.
Yeah, I did I think I almost drowned wait a minute This does
look like the island.
Have you guys ever seen the video of the island?
Oh No, it's the bees.
Don't worry.
I'll swap the bees off I'm confused.
I know I got the bee.
I got the bee.
I gotta be those bees have human faces.
They do I'm gonna put these bees away Oh, can I throw a bee
at people?
Oh shit.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, no.
Hello.
All right I'm a little confused too Can I stalk the bees?
okay i have two bees on me now i don't worry i got you okay
hold still oh my god there's five of them there's like five
bees watch this though oh shit i'm sorry i'm sorry uh uh uh
stay in Oh, no.
It's okay.
You have a lot of bees on.
Oh, wait, what happened here?
Oh, no.
Wait, wait.
I can't help this.
Stay alive.
I don't think that worked.
It's going well.
It's going really well.
Wake up, please.
We haven't even entered the property yet.
And one of us has already been decapitated.
Wake up.
How did this happen?
She didn't even go inside.
In the meantime, let me...
Britt, how did she lose her head?
Yeah.
You're the smartest one.
I'm going to go back and revive her.
CPR can regrow head, right?
Oh.
Yay!
How did you die?
Oh!
Wait, can you take off these bees?
on me yeah i got you you take these off you uh okay yeah huh
uh-huh uh-huh there we go nice i got you i got you i jumped
too high we grabbed that real quick how dare you how dare
you friendly fire what do you mean you're still alive okay
so you oh you were on your spring shoes wait does that mean
we think we can come in this way there's a window okay oh
you're right i see it oh yeah okay we got we got get fragles
to the sun and we got fine underwear and open fragles
waggles yeah there we go okay we open one we open one oh rin
okay there's a cockroach maybe maybe don't out wait out i
know what to do bug on bug oh Did that walk?
Um, yes, and...
Oh, open the window, open the window.
Wait, it's me.
Wait, go over there and open the window, Ren.
I don't know, Ren.
You...
Let me go over there.
Open the window!
I'm trying my best!
What's the point of having spring shoes is we can't even
open a window?
Okay.
I'm gonna open the drawers.
They might be in this dresser.
Yeah, it's panty rate time.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, I didn't break it.
I'm gonna try and find...
I found some toothbrushes.
I'm gonna try and open this door.
Oh, my arms are too tiny.
Oh!
Oh my god, he's naked!
He's naked!
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Can I...
Where's the nudity, but...
Why does he have a bazooka thing?
Look, he's very... That's why he's on an island.
Good.
Oh my god, he's naked.
Oh my god.
To be fair, he thinks he lives alone.
I'm going up.
If he lives alone, it makes sense not wearing anything.
Less laundry.
How are you climbing up the stairs like that?
Hardcore.
We're gamers.
Oh my god, he's coming.
He's behind us.
He's behind you.
He is absolutely behind you.
Climb faster.
Do you think she's okay?
is her leg
oh thank god her legs okay we gotta we gotta find underwear
what was that?
oh do you have under oh um he sort of might have used the
bazooka on Amelie and now all that's left of her is a foot
oh you want to see her feet it's right here look at it Oh,
wait, did he spawn?
Oh, did he spawn?
It was right here.
I touched it and everything.
Your feet are gone.
You guys made me explode?
Yeah, you're awesome.
I saw it.
I heard it.
And I'm like, what was it?
I'm pretty sure that breaking the item is in the kitchen.
I don't think we can break anything here.
Oh, wait, there's a mouse.
I break the mouse?
I can't.
Where the fuck is this guy's underwear?
How the fuck am I going to panty raid?
Yeah.
There's no underwear here.
Maybe it's in this?
Oh, I can't open his laundry.
I can't open this.
It's not here.
Where do you store underwear?
I'm going to lean her off.
Oh my god I'm gonna chop him up.
Oh, he has no protection on you guys the news there are evil
loams by the coast Do not fuck with them.
There's evil no I thought we're a family.
What color were they?
Yeah, we're supposed to be My god, you can't just ask that
What maybe they're wearing a different hat like Smurfs, you
know Maybe they are wearing.
Oh my god.
Yeah, they're from a different tribe.
Yeah, they're from a different tribe Okay, just drop him
back in to say that the optics on that are absolutely
terrible Anyway, don't go to the post again.
Oh
Oh my god You get what you deserve Oh my god.
Okay, you're fine.
You're fine.
You're so fine.
How did you?
How did you like pick it up?
I held it as tight as I could and then I kept like pressing
e and i guess i oh so it's like me in half oh i guess it's
not sharp i guess it's it got dolled out i mean i do just
have to wonder what you guys think you're accomplishing by
cutting off my mouse's legs like no judgment oh my god wait
i could drag her
okay we should res we should res them all right grab wait
there's still bees on your back let me grab it real quick
okay we see watch this wait watch this though bam look at
that I squashed it all right I'm gonna grab the other bee
there's like two more you have a huge collection of bees I
don't know why they like me so much the way I turned it off
okay I turned it off oh shit okay all right we're gonna you
guys have gotta get better at self-preservation hey what do
you mean you guys what do you mean you Guys, I...
Fight back, fight back!
What do you mean?
I was so...
Oh, oh wait, he's sleeping.
Oh, is he dead?
No, I think he's sleeping.
Oh, oh.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
He's dead.
I get the impression.
This man's life is already not going very well.
And the gnomes are just an added problem for him.
Oh, I think he is dead.
Yeah, that's a king, right.
So... Get gnomed!
Get gnomed!
Yeah, that's right.
Alright, let's go raise them.
He doesn't even wear underpants!
Oh!
Why did you... Why did it make that...
I'm trying to take him the rocket launcher.
Why did it make that sound?
Wait, why is there a hallway to nothing?
What the fuck?
Where's the front door?
I don't think he has a door.
guy this man had no door i wonder if i could move maybe past
the kitchen maybe is it past is it oh okay it's like a
murder house i mean yeah i guess we have a little bit mud
that does make sense and it's a murder house man if oh wait
where did you get right where did you get murdered so oh
you're you got murdered outside oh my god um okay Rin died
outside oh no she has no I was killed by the evil fucking
norms that kill you and kill you instantly down by the ghost
you will know if we see them yeah the window yeah we need to
find something to get to the window how do we wait we could
use them we can use them as like if we push him to the
window we can use him as like a as like a little the ramp
like this elderly man is currently in the middle of a
medical emergency it's okay he's already dead there's no
medical anymore like a stab stone we gotta use him as a
store oh my god oh my god you're so strong oh my god how did
you do that oh mouse all right all right we got this we'll
be heroes i didn't think are like ants where like they've
got a really high like like height to strength ratio oh my
god she's gaming she's really gaming okay we got the window
by the window yeah yeah he's by the window we got this now
look at him look at him oh my god we need to get closer the
sensor stops working don't get too close don't get too close
i saw his balls okay well okay That's fine.
I'm crawling.
Me too.
I'm crawling over.
I'm crawling.
Wait, which way is the mushroom?
To the front.
Just go to the front.
Yeah, keep going forward.
Don't worry.
My legs grew back.
We're rising.
Don't be on your left.
On your behind you.
Don't be behind you.
Oh, there's the evil anombs!
Oh my god.
Run, run, run.
He has no clothes on.
That one's making him evil.
all right there you go you're back oh wait there's a fairy
oh there's a under attack yes what is he what is going on
what is he what oh we don't have what she wants three
scrappling yeah i only have one They're like peppers.
We don't have what Lizzie was.
Yeah, okay, we still need to catch fragles and bring...
Oh my god.
Oh, they're peppers.
Oh, wait, no, that's not fragles.
Never mind, I have a scrappling.
Oh, God.
Oh, God, I'm going back in.
The man's dead anyway.
Alright.
It's gonna be okay.
It's gonna...
It might be okay.
Alright.
Oh, God.
Don't get near his ass.
That's a reminder Do not
What is
Oh my god why are they still outside Why are they still I
have to resurrect I'm a in a speedrun miracle has already
managed to die again how did she die oh my god they don't
even go grounded again they don't even know this is a
hostage situation aren't they curious where i went no
they're more they're like where did that's a real shame for
you and i wait how does she have wings Oh my god.
No!
Oh!
Nobody does!
I got it!
They don't care!
Now she's been abducted.
Oh, that's a real shame.
I get it.
Oh, I'm trying to make it.
I'm trying to get to the tornado.
Nobody domes.
I'm here.
No, oh, God, this is angel.
I got gnomed walls.
Nobody knows.
Nobody domes.
Please.
Have you tried asking really nicely?
Please, sir.
Open your mouth, please.
When will they come?
They'll surely come back for me.
right don't come back for me oh i died of loneliness oh
there we are what are you wearing oh my god hey guys i got
how do i take it off maybe okay let's see our performance
review guys
Hi, gnomes birdie.
Oh, that's not good.
I probably should have seen that coming in all of us.
I guess well, nobody will get the wings.
Nobody.
I put them down.
I was like, maybe you can wear them.
Never mind.
Brings new meaning to rest in pieces.
Guys, I got- We have to do all the things.
I got kidnapped.
I think we need to just do a majority of the thing.
to escape i'd love to escape don't worry i got you got you
oh we got this we keep anything we don't you start all the
way over we're bad gnomes we're bad no but i'm so bad
everything else that's it i'm bringing the bell i can't even
try we got this guys we can be employee of the gnome of the
month Guys, we're we'll be we'll be gnome of the month
She's doing her wicked rift right now Oh, oh,
janky the graphics are All right, we got we know what to do
now Guys No, any item from the kitchen kiss garden gnomes
No, wait, I know my
I open a caddum.
Stab a roach with a fork?
Where is... Where are the garden gnomes, though?
This guy has a bed.
Where are the lady gnomes at?
Yeah.
We, Emily and I know what our job is today.
I'm gonna go over here.
Where are the garden gnomes hiding, girl?
We're roaming tonight.
It's Friday night.
Ready for some smooching.
Wait, where are they?
Do you think they know I'm ready to mingle?
I'm single and ready to mingle?
Do you think they know?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, my God.
We literally went the wrong way.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, they're so jealous.
They're so jealous of me.
Oh my god, her bodyguards are here.
Hello, gnome.
Am I doing it?
Is this how you is?
Is this...
Am I...
Oh.
Like...
I know I kiss.
Smooch.
Mwah.
I'm trapped.
Do you know how to...
Do we get...
Oh!
All right, don't worry, I got you.
GG, no heals.
Okay.
I'm trying to figure out how...
GG, no heals.
Amalee, how do you kiss?
I cried for help.
Can you give me a step-by-step on how to kiss?
Is it...
Am I...
Oh, I did it!
I did it!
I kissed a gnome!
All right, all right, all right.
You turn.
Hey, there.
Don't worry.
I'm inclusive to all shapes and sizes.
Mwah.
Hello?
Oh, there we go.
I did it!
I kissed the gnomes!
Alright.
Let me go.
Res you.
Wait, what's that?
Is that hose?
Can I steal that?
There we go.
Look at that, guys.
See?
I don't need an instructional video.
That's right.
I know how to kiss.
Ladies, ladies.
I know how to kiss gnomes.
All right, let's go get her back.
Oh, it's this.
I kissed a gnome and I liked it, mom.
Ah, nah, nah, nah, nah.
All right, welcome back to you see it.
Tomoto likes you.
Oh, did you see me?
Did you see me kiss that gnome?
Did you see that?
I did.
I saw you kiss that gnome, and then Mouse is rizzing up
some, like, hot male gnome with a boombox.
Oh, my God.
Wait, what?
All right, let's go in there.
We're missing out some action.
I was really mad to be brought back to life because I was
enjoying watching Mouse.
But they already stole that stolen item from the kitchen.
Oh, I think we got breaking through a window again.
Can I boost?
you no i'm pretty sure it's a window situation i'm gonna go
over to the yeah wait they already opened a cabinet yeah
they're doing so much wait what happened did the boombox man
kill you wait you go res there by bees oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah they got me too
whoop that dunk how do i open doors short how do i how do i
oh wait i can raise my hands like i don't care come on come
on open the door don't raise my hand like i don't care ah
grin can you open the door
please i'm stuck in the
JK.
I'm no liars.
Oh.
I wonder who's... Must have been the wind.
Ah!
This is not karma.
Oh, hey, guys.
Hey.
What did you win?
He's throwing you.
You're getting evicted.
You're fine.
I know there was a... Oh, there it is.
Alright.
Huh.
Can't stop me!
I found a marble.
Have you guys found a gravel yet?
I thought this was one of those.
Well, by now.
Do you know gravel?
Where the fuck?
This guy's house is too big.
I'm just trying to find a fork, so...
can stab a small creature to death i found a mouse trap here
how do we use it what trap a mouse trap say that again
there's a mouse trap look say that again i guess you can't
now yeah
rest me rest me i get i get your baby girl Don't you worry.
I'm not sure if we have Razz's left, though.
We used all our Razz's?
I've only done...
Oh, yay.
Yippee.
What the hell is grapple?
I don't know.
Stab a rope with a fork.
Wait.
We have eight minutes.
Grab them just done after stealing.
Gravel is gathered, contained naturally occurring.
These include...
Oh!
Wait, if you click...
It's wood, stone, and paper.
in organic materials.
That's what gravel is.
How the fuck am I gonna get wood?
It's anything you can grab.
That's why it's called gravel.
That's what gravel means.
It's anything you can grab.
Like if you click press tab, click gravel, and then look at
it.
It's really, oh my god.
It's anything you can grab!
We figured it out!
We figured it out.
Gravel is.
It's all coming together.
Oh my god.
I saw a gravel tour, too.
Rin!
I don't want to grab!
It's anything you can grab!
It's gravel is any item you can grab!
And that's why it's called gravel!
Press tab, press tab, click gravel!
And then look at the gravel tab!
I'm grabbing my, where's my notebook?
I'm so confused.
It's literally any item.
That's just sounds like a madman.
Where's the notebook?
I threw a notebook out here.
What happened to my notebook?
Oh, wait.
Oh, wait, I think somebody picked it up.
We need one more.
We need one more item to grab.
What the hell?
Oh my god.
Gravel.
Gravel is any item you can grab, Amelie.
It's any item you can click it.
Click tap.
Click on gravel.
It tells you everything.
It's literally any item you can grab.
That's why it's called gravel.
I can gravel.
Wait, do we have to put it in the thing?
Yeah, yeah, I'm grabbing it.
That's why it's gravel.
Go, go, go, go!
Okay.
You're here.
I have it here.
Give it me!
Give it!
Let go!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Go, go, go!
We're doing it!
It's okay!
Guys, did we learn nothing?
And my leg can grow back!
Where's the mouse?
We got it!
We grabbed it!
No, he's got the mouse!
That's our gravel!
I'm just running for the sake of it!
Get him!
My brat!
No!
Wait, what's this?
Are you okay?
Is this not gravel?
No, it's a scrappling.
It doesn't count.
Did it steal it from you?
No!
He took our...
He took our gravel!
After everything Okay, we still need one more Wait, can I
steal this?
Oh, I can't steal this What can I steal?
Oh, my god Oh, I can steal this Steal some firewood It's
okay, no, I got That's not actually mom Oh, my god, oh my
god, please We should go Oh, my god, he has a bow Oh, fuck
No God, get the pillow
The pillow and run
Oh, please just throw me away.
Don't put me in the oven.
Oh, God.
Hey.
Oh, no.
Yes.
What the fuck is it?
Did she not take the...
I swear to God.
Did she not... I swear to God, Rin.
Did you not take the pillow?
Where did she put the pillow?
Oh, my God, is I mouse dead?
I'm cooked.
I was like, man, I'm gone.
So I feel like that's entirely...
Oh.
That's a real shame.
What happened to these guys?
Oh, my God.
I was so close.
This is the worst day ever.
You think the fork on my body counts as grapple?
Oh, shit.
Oh, no, they're gonna flush her away.
Okay, at least she's still alive, unlike me.
No, we.
Just a bit away of going back in the house now that I know
that he has a loaded...
Oh, my God.
The found dead and no one jerked it breaks how would they
know to ever save me is there anyone's left alive red is
alive but me and Doki died uh-oh okay maybe I can res you
and then you guys can take the fork from my body no I double
clicked here we go Rin Rin can we can we have a fork there's
a fork on my body if you take it off maybe it's grapple I
was wondering yeah Take the cool off my body.
Is it gravel?
How do I do this?
Grab it and pull it.
Is that gravel?
Oh, there we are.
Yeah, there you go.
There you go.
And then we're going to bring it back to the plane.
How did you die?
Oh, and then we can...
Did he shot you?
Grable it, I presume.
Oh, it's not gravel.
It's not gravel.
It's still two out of three.
You got...
We've done enough.
And we only have one minute.
No, you guys got this.
Leo.
No, come on.
You just need one more.
It's anything you can grab.
That's why it's gravels.
Wait, we can grab some really fast.
You just need paper.
We have literally one minute.
Paper, wood, pebbles, anything made of organic material.
Anything.
Just... Organic?
What about this?
What about these?
You can't grab wood.
I tried.
That's wrong.
my lesson what about one of these i know he's gonna bite you
is that organic oh my god when it was what's organic the
plants what's organic plants life oh the tornadoes here the
tornado the uber is here anywhere else other than here go go
go go go now i've picked a lot of bees with us um
We'll find out.
I love bees.
Bees love me.
Woo!
Why couldn't I pick up that firewood, huh?
That's organic.
I don't think Amelie knows the definition of organic.
My god, bratty set with a 5,000 bitty?
Holy shit.
Thank you so much.
Holy crap, thank you.
Red.
Oh, there's red.
This time chatter too.
Big love, big love.
All right.
Why do you invoke Christ's name when clearly he's not here?
Bring us back.
Come back, please.
What the fuck?
Oh, hello.
We're reborn now.
What happened?
Why are you all crisp?
some gravel we got caught i also i got grabbed trying to get
gravel do we win it's okay four out of five ain't bad the
shot got it you were one of the victims i think we have to
get three of five and then okay and then we get his approval
that's good dom said two we got two no meal award rewards we
all have to be alive at the end to actually yeah do we get
more rewards to get like pour some shit this is a these
gravestones yeah that's how that's where we died that's how
yeah again my god someone didn't save us that's not my grave
listen i tried and we were out of charges so to some point
you don't need yourself to blame you know you can save
people before they die you know that's possible ren ray you
know you can save people news to me you can use res for five
minutes in that oven, Rin, for five minutes.
Listen, if you lost in five minutes in the oven, at that
point, it's on you if you don't lost any longer.
You get a smacker.
Solid self-defense against smaller enemies.
Oh, you can... You could use it to be against the
cockroaches, wouldn't it?
I've used it, so thank you, thank you.
You could use it for the evil gnomes.
Oh, gnomes without clothes.
Oh, go ahead.
Who wants to fight back?
I'll fight back.
a snacker i want to fight back i'll buy it back right back
that's right wait what does it look like if i jump off are
you sure that's oh oh my and you learned nothing oh i didn't
what do you mean i didn't do anything make the jump make the
thing maybe make the jump all right but what if i Oh, do a
flip.
No, she will be born again.
What was that?
Born again.
You all hear someone?
Oh.
Born again.
I was born again.
Wait, how do we change the map?
Oh, it's here on the fountain, the magic fountain.
All right.
Do I think we have to change the map each time?
Or swap plot?
Which one?
The forest?
The forest looks accommodating and therefore it's probably
going to be terrible.
So we should do the forest.
Don't worry.
I have self-defense now.
I have a bet.
Oh, protect us.
Jokey, DPS.
Don't worry, I'll DPS.
That's where I got the smacker.
Miraco.
I'm ready to smack.
Smack you smack.
Oh, all right.
What's her task?
What's our mission?
Oh, so you got the right item for that.
Kiss garden noobs?
Alright.
See an item from the...
Okay.
Alright, I got the roach.
We can do this.
Alright, we got this guys.
We got this.
We can beat level two.
Oh, whoa.
Yeah, we gotta go on the bridge.
You can probably drown.
I think so.
We're so tiny.
Probably, yeah.
Much slightly.
Okay, let's look for a window.
And guys, let's remember when we leave the window, let's
climb up the side so we don't break our legs.
How's that sound, huh?
That doesn't sound as fire.
fun but what if i did want to break my legs i mean oh wait
there's a there's a basement window wait can i break oh yeah
good i got you i did it that's right that's right let's try
not to break all of all like there's a roach there's a roach
oh i'm gonna get his ass where is he That's right.
You're in the wrong hood.
Get him!
Oh my god, he's so fast.
Oh my god, got him.
That's right.
You're in the wrong neighborhood.
This is gnome territory.
No, his legs are still moving.
All right, now he's dead.
I mean, it says we've killed the wrong child.
There we go.
Yeah, it's just a nervous system.
Yeah, we had to double tap.
It might turn into a zombie.
You always remember to double tap.
Alright.
Stop fighting.
What else we need?
We gotta break an item.
Oh, Amalie kissed the gnomes.
I kissed the gnomes.
You kissed the gnomes.
Oh, no.
Did you fall down the stairs?
There's nothing flammable for no reason.
Break item.
How do you break item?
You just smack it.
You can just pick it up and smash it.
Don't you mind me.
Wait, I'm not tall.
My hands are not tall enough.
This is always our problem.
Our hands are never tall enough for this.
We can use this as a little booster, right?
Anything flammable so we can...
Can you break into the sea?
Be fine and normal about it.
Wait, we're going to use this as a booster.
Oh!
Oh, my out!
oh no no no should not it's all right i can regrow it we
gotta use this as a little booster seat okay but what have
we got in the rest of the house let's have a look i'm trying
to wait guys guys i'm gonna bring this up as a booster i got
it wait we got it how did you do that head it was oh
teamwork guys oh we gotta steal something from the hallway
too if you see anything hey what constitutes is a hallway
anything that's in the hall
all right is there anything up here no
where are we still need a this we see flush an item from a
toilet wait this killer roach break any item wait this up
there there's there's there's porcelain up here i broke two
do you see all those glasses wait wait boost boost i'll
boost you here go drawer here use my head okay okay i'm
trying i'm trying use it hey i can't get up there's a gun we
gotta grab the gun or not we gotta self-defense How do I
climb here?
Use my head use my head here.
Oh my god.
I did I did my parkord.
I parkord.
I'm grabbing the gun Where is it?
Where's the gun as a gun?
Here mouse climb on my head here here All right, got another
item.
Yes, you guys.
Oh wait, I see it.
I see the gun
Self-defense through the gun we can use this to how do I oh
wait oh first where's the last glass guy all right I broke
the last item we just need a flush and I know we need to
steal it and flush an item we can flush the gun flush maybe
a fork he's coming don't worry I don't worry he's coming
don't worry I'm getting my gun ready I just okay I'm maybe
oh my god oh my god the murder oh my god you're a murderer
yeah you're a human life oh my god I'm a better I won't be
the last I'm a We got to flush the gun.
We got to flush the gun.
We got to flush the gun in the bathroom.
It was self-defense.
Where's the bathroom?
We have to flush the evidence.
Wait, wait, is that the bathroom?
Wait, wait, I'll give you a boost.
Here, let's see if this is the bathroom.
I'm gonna open the door, open the door.
I can step on my head.
Okay, okay, I'll step on your head.
Oh my god, maybe it runs the best at this.
I'm not good at this.
Oh, I got it.
Okay, okay, that's not the bathroom.
This is not the bathroom.
Rin, have you found the bathroom?
I need to flush this.
I can't have this link.
I can't go back.
Not again.
Oh, God.
I can't go back.
I have a family to provide for.
Rin, is there a bathroom up here?
Yeah.
I have, I have the evidence to flush.
Hurry, hurry before the cops show up.
I know.
I need to clean the fingerprints.
I can't go back.
It's okay.
It's water.
It'll wash them off, surely.
Okay.
Is it in?
Oh my God.
I missed.
It's okay.
Here we go.
No!
No, we're- No!
Jesus, oh, not again.
I'm such a close.
Oh my God.
my mind okay i got it i got it all right let go let go
eventually go let go i got it let go all right i'm almost
there it's in it's in flush it oh we did it they'll never
trace the crime back to us yes they're a picky noise all
right we got fine we got stealing item in the hallway all
right now that he's dead wait can i steal a mouse trap does
that count
does that count guys the perfect crime yeah I was thinking
that too wait well I'll steal this this is part of the hall
technically no we didn't there's no evidence to say that we
did we were never there oh my god we're just this guy is
dead anyway so we're doing him a favor by uh reclaiming
giving his new items at home you know so true how do we get
out of here where is his normal door maybe this we jump up
here i don't know we can reach that we drag a can we drag a
chair over we could drag his dead body that's what my
armhouse and i did last time all right here we go we could
do that all right how do i i don't remember how i it last
time what are those squeakies wait this is the door right
here what how do i do this i feel wrong just caressing this
handle
hey there he's right oh shit
Oh, I break it?
Okay, this doesn't break it.
This doesn't break it, guys.
How do we get out of here?
I'm so confused.
Yeah, no, he's dead.
I shot him in the heart.
Do not jump outside that window.
Which window?
Yeah, I'm bored of saying.
Oh, for any particular reason or anything.
We're trying to figure out how to get out of here.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Maybe we can use this.
Is there another window that's easier to get out of here?
I got it, I got it.
Here, here.
Here, pick this up.
This door sucks.
That's a window.
Here.
Pick it up.
Give it to me.
Okay.
Not sure if that counted.
Grip me.
Wait, where did you get that from?
Because it needs to be from a hallway.
That was from the hallway.
did it count i don't know we have to we have to get it to
our house no god oh no oh no oh no oh no oh this is bad oh
no this is so bad this is so bad wait wait this is so bad oh
god oh my god here stand on my head i'm on this stand on my
head wait can i push this okay okay
oh you do it i can't do it i'm too short oh god how do we
how do we get out of here i'm just gonna bring objects here
in case one of them doesn't come away away i'm gonna oh
you're right i'm gonna flush myself outside oh my god you're
so smart okay i'm gonna parkour i'll bring her back to all
right we're just gonna flush ourselves out i wonder if i can
bring the technically the gun was in the hallway if you
think about it all right oh what the who
put who put the mouse trap on the toilet let me show you how
it's done son now we go you get it you get it who put who
put the on the toilet who was who was that was that only
apologize the goal of my contact campaign okay could I have
my spoils of war please oh my god what the fuck was that
ignore whatever that is okay yeah that's probably for best
wait no Resus!
Resus!
Bring us back!
Oh god!
Don't worry!
I'm gonna go do that!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then I can get back on here later.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's more important!
I'm telling everyone not to...
Go over.
I did it to myself.
I'm a fool.
Go over.
And it was a rhythm was the one that was like...
Clam...
Remember the clam?
The...
The things?
Oh, the evil no more.
oh shit oh there's the evil no everything's gonna be fine oh
wait the evil nooms are scared and if it's not then that's a
later me problem why is he so scared you open this fridge
i'm gonna go down in generations people are gonna speak my
name for years wow do you know that one norm yeah the one
who was really good at text notes uh yeah you're showing a
guy in the heart someone that put a mouse trap in the
bathroom yeah that gnome that one yeah that gnome why is
there an evil fucking gnome here oh my god oh my god just
res just res us will protect you oh my god it's okay it's
okay okay we did not okay we did not protect her i'm just
gonna run Oh my god Wait I flushed Wait I got an idea Is the
gun still outside?
Guys, gnomes can't swim Wait Guys, gnomes can't swim Guys,
do not go into the water Do not go into the water Gnomes
cannot swim Gnomes cannot swim No No But we can float though
Don't worry, I'll slowly float down the river.
I don't know.
Grab me, yes!
Oh god!
This is what I tried to warn you about last time.
So gnomes can't swim.
If you guys didn't know that.
Wait, unless...
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Oh!
Stop!
Oh
Wait, wait, wait I believe I believe you can clutch this No,
you didn't get flushed What, it won't flush?
Oh no, oh no I'm Mousy has to, Mousy has to get out No,
she's the only home She's our only home Mousy, Mousy Get to
the tornado the tornado you're the only one left you have to
get to the tornado you're our only home you're our only home
girl you gotta get out she's almost there she's almost there
no she made it goodbye goodbye i'll believe no you're gonna
be trapped here for the rest of your life you know just take
your time there's absolutely no rush not like anyone's
waiting for you or anything dude goodbye at least in the end
our best lives
all your friends are dead all your friends are dead oh we're
live born again born again oh man Did we do it?
Did we do it?
Did we complete our task?
I think we really tried.
We really fumbled this one, boys.
Guys, we got it.
We must have made it.
We're gonna get 5 out of 5.
No, we got it.
We got it.
High Noam's verdict.
Yes!
How did we do that?
We did it.
Guys, you did it, Mousy.
You clutched it for us.
You did it.
I was so scared.
You were there.
I gave up right as I unful of the toilet.
Like, really?
Oh no, oh god damn.
Oh, the world.
You feel like the lot has become more hostile.
There's, it can turn already once.
I know I was going to say, it can get worse.
It can get worse.
It can be pretty stacked against.
Island mountaintop.
Oh.
We should go try mountaintop.
We haven't tried that yet.
All right, let's grab.
We should grab.
I feel like the smacker came in clutch.
I feel like we should get that again.
Yeah, the smacker was amazing.
Being able to break the windows is very nice.
Yeah, I'll grab that again.
I bought it.
Whoa, whoa.
I saw that.
I saw that what that tongue was doing.
The tongue, what the gnome doing?
No, no, what the, yeah, what that gnome doing?
All right, here we go.
What is the white gloves?
What do they do?
The entire time I've been saying it.
Can I even use the toilet?
one again why is there a helipad here i guess we'll never
know mountain top whoa this guy has a garage in the mountain
yeah that's a garage here how the hell you get in the car up
here if you need to maybe it's a helicopter maybe it's where
she keeps our helicopter yeah it's like a transformer yeah
you know some people just keep cars just to look at it they
don't use it because they'll add miles to it yeah be careful
don't go too close oh yeah i you know what it's due to the
bees that's taking red up wait what are we supposed to do
open the garage door remote gather clonk break any saba
roach with a knife and steal food okay we gotta there's a
lot of stuff we gotta do wait so it has to be a knife not a
fork this concerns me someone Nope.
Is there a window in here?
Wait, maybe you need a booster.
I'm gonna break this window.
Oh, I gotta stab a roach.
Oh, the white gloves make you feel like Spider-Man.
That seems very helpful, actually.
Alright.
That's fucking...
No!
Guys!
Yes!
Oh wait.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, it's a poopling.
It's a little poopling.
Okay, gatter clog.
What the fuck is clog?
Containing metal.
Uh...
Seep safe in drawers.
How do I steal food?
Okay.
Food.
All right.
It's fine.
It's all right.
I still have my smacker.
I can still finish the job.
All right.
I'm back in here.
Did you kill anything with that?
Oh, shit.
Wait, how did you die?
I'll go back and raise you.
I'm so skinny.
The wind blew me away.
Wait, really?
The wind blew you away?
That's possible?
must have been the wind all right let's go get her back you
don't believe me you don't believe that I'm just so I'm a
skinny legend um that's bait that's a trap right there I'm
not gonna answer that that's a trap you set that up for me
I'm not gonna you're like it's like it's like yeah I got it
I got her I got her Got something of a B problem.
Yeah?
All right, we got nothing.
Yeah, it's fine.
It's my little buddy.
Of course, emotional support.
What happened to your weapon?
It's right here.
Yeah, yeah.
The wind, the wind, be careful, be careful.
Wait a second.
Oh, hey, I gave him a kiss.
It's not even an objective.
She's just doing it Yeah, yeah, do it for the love.
Yeah.
Alright.
Oh shit, wait.
Look at this.
Oh.
Just steal food.
Wait, does fish count as food?
Yeah, can you steal the fish?
Hey guys, I forgot.
Noom's can't swim.
Are you drowning?
You're alive.
Noom's can't swim, guys.
He's coming, he's coming, he's coming.
Please, please.
Oh!
He has a gun!
I repeat.
He has a gun.
okay he just oh that was scary i just saw i don't know who
he shot and get down
who the fuck did he shot who
did he shoot do you know rain oh my god wait wait i got it
here here pass it it's like it's like soccer it's like
basketball Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Don't get to be if I'm here.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I can grow my legs back.
In five, four, three, two, one.
All right, I'm back.
All right.
Pass it.
Gotcha.
It's like basketball.
It's free throw it.
I'm right here.
Oh, I almost...
got it oh my god it's so close wait wait just bring it over
to that counter to your left chuck it to that counter to
your left and then climb up yeah yeah yeah yeah oh it's so
smart yeah yeah and then so like i got it both dead okay but
we got canned food we can revive you oh it's okay
I don't know what could mean food.
And I got shot.
It's okay.
We got food.
Oh my god.
He's outside.
He's coming.
He can go outside.
Wait.
What if I can smack his lid?
Wait, wait.
Is he going to bend down?
Get out of the ankles.
Go.
Bite him off.
You can do this.
Yeah, I'm going to try.
Grab him.
Kill him.
Bite his ankles.
Watch this, guys.
Wait.
Did we get him?
the clock.
Wait, wait.
He grabbed our clock.
Okay, well, I'll go res.
Alright.
You can go back inside.
I'll go res.
It's alright.
I can take a little.
I can take one B.
I can take two Bs.
Oh, God.
I can tank it.
Alright.
Don't worry, I got you guys.
I'm almost there.
There you go.
Welcome back.
Born again.
All right, yeah, grab those bees up.
And if you can grab it, you can throw it on the floor and
they die.
Ow.
It's on me now.
You have to throw it on the floor.
I stole my can.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
We...
Oh.
My stick.
We're all, we're all skinny.
We're all skinny.
We're all so skinny.
I haven't completed anything.
No, it's okay.
We still have time, but we might not have a stick.
We have to get into the garage.
All right, all right, all right.
We gotta go.
It's in the drawers.
Apparently the remote is in the drawers.
Wait, he opened the door.
Guys, there's a chance.
There's a chance.
We have a chance.
chance we can go through the front door start breaking items
oh god oh no it's okay i can take you guys can someone grab
that bee from my face yeah yeah so i got you okay we gotta
break shit start breaking go in the kitchen break shit
there's a i see some oh if only i have my stick
We got a break, Shay.
Any pots, any pans, any glasses?
Wait, there's a pot.
There's a pan.
A knife.
There's a knife.
Wait, we got to stab the roach with a knife.
What is this?
Is this food?
Is that not?
I got cigarettes.
This is not food.
Not food.
Not breakable.
Oh, oh, there's a rat!
A rat.
There's a rat.
Okay, wait, wait.
I found that.
Break that.
I found another knife.
Wait, can you...
Got a knife?
And then, oh my god, I'm trying to...
Please.
I got...
I broke something, I broke something.
I got the knife.
Climb, climb, climb!
I'm gonna...
I'm trying...
Oh!
I got my own leg up!
Oh no.
I got my own...
No, please don't grab me while I'm down.
Not like this.
Please don't.
him wait how do i climb on this how do i climb yeah i'm
cutting him guys i'm a hero
i'll save you i'll save you jockey i cut him already why
doesn't he die no oh my god he chucked me off the mountain
I might be dead.
He might have threw me off the mountain.
Understandable.
He might have had a feeling.
He might have thrown me off the mountain.
I might need...
I mean, the good news is I did manage to go to him into
shooting his own window like a stupid idiot.
So, psychologically, I feel like we've already won.
I found a knife.
Let me see if I can fix this.
I'm only has it.
We just need to find a roach now.
Oh, that...
Wait, if you're...
My body's gone and I'm out of charges.
Oh.
No.
Can I break this?
So I found you.
Nice.
My knife.
Is that?
Is that good?
Yeah.
Knife is metal, so that's a clunk.
It's considered a clunk.
Oh, wonderful.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, oh, we still haven't gathered anything.
We've completed nothing.
There's another knife.
There's another knife in there.
I haven't even...
You know what?
I'm getting...
I'm going to grab my food.
I'm bringing it back.
I'm dead anyway.
Guys, I don't think we're going to...
Guys, I don't think we're beating this level.
I don't think we're beating this level.
Oh!
Oh my god, we broke all the items.
One.
We did it.
I'm going to grab food.
I'll be right back, guys.
That window,
that stupid idiot broke.
Hey, so it's just you left, I think.
Oh.
Oh, that...
That can't be good.
It's just you.
Okay, oh, Jesus shit.
What the fuck happened?
I can do this.
I'm on the mission.
And the mission is breaking my camera.
a little bit but that's okay what happened what happened i
just came back this is just like that one movie metal items
the front door is open just metal items oh my god okay metal
items what happened uh that looks metallic to me here we go
that sounds metallic to me no that is not a door that is a
fridge oh no oh oh he doesn't know stupid idiot went outside
his house knowing fully is all invaded right now wait they
all you guys all got shot he knows run run run there's a
non-zero chance he knows oh my god he's not looking at me
why does he just not looking at me he has a gun stupid i'm
fully aware he's got a gun don't you worry about that oh
five thousand cigarettes
guys are we bad gnomes are we
bad gnomes
is there an easy mode guys guys this is the run in the hit
movie home alone I'm realizing now maybe we are the problem
guys no this is the run this is the run this is the one I
have to pee really fast but you can start the game you can
start the game I'll be back I'll be back but they're gonna
kill us oh okay don't worry I died before he kills me.
That's right.
Oh.
I didn't even do anything, though.
It's okay.
I went off on my own terms.
No, I'm happy for you in that case.
Guys.
Guys, this is the run.
This is the run, guys.
I believe it.
We're veterans.
Now that we know how to play this game, now that we know yes
yes i'm not necessarily sure now that we know we're gonna be
gamers we do one more because i feel like the one more run
really one more run okay okay one yeah we do it until we die
we can do this we do this we can beat this game
all right get the fragles what the fragles what the fragles
is can we get it fragile items that's why it's fragled it's
ceramics or glass that makes slightly more sense because
it's fragile oh get it get jonathan out of his hut he is
strong he lives in there oh it's the boom box guy how did
you get Jonathan out of his hut.
What do you mean there's a boombox guy?
He is strong.
He lives in a tiny hut.
Oh, he's telling you, like the little wooden shed earlier.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We gotta get him out.
Oh, I was wondering who that was.
That's Jonathan.
Alright, I'm going up.
Let's worry about him later, because for now we have a home
invasion to do.
We just need to find a gun, and then, as the game, as the
shooter here.
What was that?
Whoa.
nice trees there's a toaster let me oh i opened two windows
i already i two for one two for one two for one i'm doing it
let me open this cabinet make it three oh my god look at her
go look at her go rin's doing it she's gaming she's gnoming
out you just need to stop breaking shit are we alive are you
guys alive yeah yeah we're live right now oh my god i got i
got this i got i got a fraggle picking this fraggle up i'm
gonna go all right i guess i'll break it no we no we don't
break this we gotta what are fraggles it's fragile items
ceramics glass your mountains on his way oh my god oh my god
he didn't see me
You didn't see me.
I got the fraggle.
I gotta use the fraggle.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
My grabber.
Go grab!
Okay.
I got one fraggle.
Stop breaking fraggles!
Eh.
Oh, go ahead.
No!
This is not good.
This is...
This might not be good.
I...
Remember something.
Oh, no.
Gnome.
How do you have to help us out?
Oh, no.
Oh, wait, we got Jonathan out.
What the?
How did he got Jonathan out?
Oh, my God.
It's all up to...
We got Roomba.
Help.
Don't go back.
Oh, no.
Mass.
scream start screaming um so there's been a couple
casualties come on you're still alive I'm impressed okay we
need to go find Doki because she's been kidnapped by a room
The Roomba!
Please!
I'm still in here!
Help!
Oh look at that, you got caught!
Hey!
Hey, that's me in the Roomba!
That's me in the Roomba!
Help!
Jonathan!
What?
What happened?
It's not in the dog.
What the fuck happened to him?
What happened?
Oh my god, I'm still trapped here for the rest of my life.
I
You got rocket launcher.
Yeah, I kind of exploded myself.
Oh, oh, I killed Jonathan How can you live with yourself
after that?
Oh, I'm dead.
Bye, but um, Riz, Riz, Riz, Riz Doki's in the machine.
No, Doki's dead.
Doki's dead.
Again What is happening to you?
I got oh no Let's not make that four out of four Okay The
rumor is coming Do not do not get near the room Do not get
near the room but You gotta get out the door But no
guarantees It's all up to you Oh my god Oh my god No no no
Maybe if we're lucky he'll just throw her out the window You
know This will let me out I'm sure Shelly okay she's almost
there the door the door is right there something bad
happened to you jonathan lived did you see that let me out
let me out let me out oh a marble let me out let me out okay
would i do like marbles hope i hope to get i hope i hope he
grabs her scrapling anyway time to get the out is what i
need we're still two more fraggles oh my god
everyone say please please please do it there we go I will
never say please I was a bit consigning for a few seconds oh
my god we just need two fragments I'll never say please I'd
rather die but you can't do it you have to res all of us you
can't pick and choose you can't pick and choose Oh, we need
two more frag two more fragles What the fuck is a frag?
Oh my god.
It's it's fragile.
That's why.
Oh, there's a fragle.
There's a fragle Okay, we gotta break it Okay Break it break
it We steal them.
We don't oh wait.
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah.
Gather it.
Yeah.
Yeah All right, don't worry.
Our grabber guy is coming over this thing will come and grab
it.
Yeah.
Yeah Oh one at a time Yeah, we got some We did it.
We did it, guys.
We did it with the ring.
Wait, can we just go home?
Wait, are we requesting extraction?
Yay!
Wee!
I don't think we told Rin.
I forgot to tell her.
I...
You
think Rin made it?
We might have just extracted without her.
Oh, no.
made she definitely made it yeah friend are you in here open
up open your new in here all right captain please she's she
saved us and we just left your behind oh no she's not
screaming how could you know the things you get we did it
yeah oh she made it she made it she made it oh my god no
she's right here she's right here oh she's here amazing yeah
we knew she was gonna make it we were so confident found
some scrapling for you oh nice that was smooth though that
was incredible that was smooth as hell allows you to fondle
things apparently away as a human one oh wait glue gloves
are really handling grappling gun oh we don't have a lot of
stuff though we would have gone yeah we're gonna have the
nomium for that now that we've got like a five out of five
he's happy well that he said we all lived norm's dead zero
whoa five baby five no we're rich as hell baby let's go how
will this
We can't afford it.
We're poor, though.
Wait, we have Nomeo gloves.
Unlatching doors, opening cabinets, and it allows you to
follow things in a similar way as a human would.
What's that even?
Unlatching doors will probably actually be quite useful.
All right, someone should grab that.
Yeah, someone make that right now.
I know you're not me.
I got it.
I got no.
You are the most responsible.
You are so responsible.
You saved us.
We're the most responsible.
Yeah.
We did pick them back.
We didn't pick them back.
Oh, what's our map?
What did we pick?
We didn't pick a map.
I don't know where we're going.
No!
Where are we going?
Oh, it's the forest.
There we go.
Okay, it's the forest.
That's fine.
Don't worry, guys.
I have the...
Did it choose for us?
Yeah, I think it chose for us, and we don't pick all right
we got oh we got kiss the no kill of rose gather plastic
wait travel through the sewer system all right i got i got
it i got i think it's the toilet situation all right don't
make a lot more sense look at this look at that yeah i'm an
expert all right we got open a cabinet gather plastic all
right guys i'll do the kissing part the hardest job don't
I'll sacrifice myself for the hardest job.
Where are the others?
Where are the other gnomes?
I'm here to kiss you.
Whoa.
Oh, there you are.
Hey there.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I did ask for consent.
I asked for consent.
I swear to God.
Okay.
It's okay.
guys i did ask for consent if i could kiss the dome that is
a dog oh no please don't tell me there is a gnome in there
that is a pit bull outside okay all right i hope there is no
gnome in there just in case no there's no no gnome no gnome
wait wait is there a gnome in there
place for himself jealous what the fuck are the other gnomes
where's my gnomes i'm not a gnomes i'm not a good elf i'm a
gnome and you've been no i'm sorry that's like in my head
right now yeah but we have to oh we have i think we gotta
get flushed for that i can't find the last gnome
It's my current stem.
Where's the last gnome?
Oh my god, it's up there.
Oh, but the bees are there.
Okay, I gotta make a sacrifice.
I am sacrificing myself for the greater good.
Okay, he doesn't know.
Oh, there we go.
That's fine.
I did it.
For the greater good.
sacrifice myself for the gnomes i'm a hero for the glory of
gnomes everywhere i am a hero okay i kill a brooch travel
through the what is going on over there how have they not
done any of these oh gather plastic
is everything okay over there Oh, wait, I found the roach.
Can someone kill it?
I don't have a weapon.
Can I kill it with my arm?
Oh, my God.
Nope, nope, nope, nope.
Nope, nope.
He's angry.
Guys, I found a no.
I found a roach.
Oh!
Oh, my God.
Oh, my.
Hey, guys, guys.
This guy has a shotgun.
Remember to open the oven for me?
Hey, guys.
Hey.
Enough.
Got you.
I got you, baby girl.
Yeah.
I got you.
I'm free.
Why?
I'm a lot.
Mouse is in the microwave.
Wait, she's in the microwave?
Yeah, it's up there.
I don't know how to get up there, though.
happen oh what if she mouse in there with you no i hear a
little mouse that's no okay 10 minutes left we have to
gather plat is he still in the house is he still inside the
kitchen he's gone he's gone he's gone okay okay we have to
somehow what happened to your grabby how do we climb Oh my
god.
Can you climb on my head?
Oh my god, I'm trying so hard.
Oh.
I'm trying so hard right now.
I don't know if this is working.
He's back.
He's washing his face.
I'm leaving.
I'm sorry.
It's okay.
I think we might.
I think we might have the...
Okay, don't worry.
Calm down for the basement.
I'll explain it later in a bit.
Oh!
Hello!
He's just throwing me out.
It's fine.
Alright.
No, I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
Guys, I'm alive.
Maybe we should have bought a stick.
Wait, is Mousy fully cooked in the microwave?
Well, I like that he doesn't shoot his gun.
I mean, that's nice, you know?
Okay.
I hear the Oh, there's that roach.
We just don't have anything to kill the roach with right
now.
Oh, here's another roach.
Oh, oh.
He was running from them.
Oh!
Mouse, you're alive.
Oh, my God, you saved me.
Hey, I got you.
I got you.
I don't know how I did it.
I got shotgunned.
So, I might, may or may not have got shot in the face.
We need to find something.
Oh, my God.
Are you all right?
Mouse, don't jump down.
Can you...
We have to get some plastic.
We have to get plaster.
Is there any plaster in here?
Oh.
Wait, that's plastic.
That's plastic.
No, no, no.
Bring it outside.
Put it outside.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Here, here, here.
Grab it.
Basketball, basketball.
Just like how we practiced.
Grab it.
Oh, I got it.
No, grab it.
You grabbing it?
I'm trying.
Okay, guys.
The good news is I think the thing we're looking for might
be on the pool table downstairs.
Matt knows as he's got a shotgun and I'm extremely dead.
What about this drawer, Mouse?
Oh!
Okay.
Wait, Mouse, Mouse, Rizus!
Riz, Brendan, now we're dead!
We got fucked!
I'm going!
We got to bring that closer to the grab guy.
Oh my god.
We are very, very much dead.
Is that Ashley Plastic?
Why is he coming alive to grab it?
Is he not here?
My tiny feet.
I think.
Oh, wait, wait.
Wait.
Maybe it is.
Oh, I don't think that was.
I don't.
Yeah, I don't think that's.
Oh.
Oh, it is.
It is.
He just didn't care about you.
Oh, it counts.
He doesn't care about me.
He just.
He just killed.
Okay, we got killed.
Rude.
I got the microwave.
We were trying in our defense.
We're making it.
attempt we tried that one wait to go through okay dude have
you found the bathroom i see the bathrooms upstairs i think
we saw a bathroom we gotta kill a roach we don't have
anything that can kill it we should dump them in the tent we
have found them is that the bathroom wait i found the
bathroom oh my god flush yourself now flush me now
God.
All right.
Oh, we flushed our each other.
We did it.
All right.
We just gotta we can float though.
No one's can't float.
All right.
We just gotta kill the roach.
That's all we need.
How do we kill the roach?
How do we?
There's a cat.
That's not a cat.
That is not a cat.
Absolutely not a cat.
I believe that is.
That is not a cat.
is a dog.
We just need to kill a roach and we're done.
What is that?
Oh, I thought that was a knife.
We all we need to do is kill a roach.
That's all we need to do.
I saw like 20 roaches.
We just don't have a weapon.
Oh, but he does.
That's all right.
Gang, you might want to be careful.
It's all right.
Dodged and weaved.
That's how you be gamer wait roach number one oh my god five
minutes left please I legit just need I just needed
something to kill him just one thing oh shit what did I fall
on what the fuck what did I trip on oh that please anything
is there anything surely oh my god is that a spoon I can
kill a roach with that how about can I kill a roach with a
spoon I feel like it'd be a fork right oh god oh yeah surely
there's any weapon
Anywhere So we're all extremely dead.
Oh just you.
It's just you.
It's just a dog.
You got the dog.
I think you should just leave What?
Oh my god.
Why did you invent the dog out?
Let the dogs out.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
All right.
We just gotta leave There's a dog now.
I can be the hero that we always Correction.
There is a very empty green Ravenous kind of dog.
Oh.
No, but then it's like so close.
It's okay.
I got the door.
The door is next to the house.
Hey, look.
See, there's the roach.
Oh my God.
I hear the dog.
It's okay.
It'll be a shame of that room, but it hits me right here.
All right.
Where is the dog?
Just run.
I'm just running.
I'm running.
You don't even look back.
I'm running as fast as I can!
I'm running!
Okay, welcome back.
Nothing behind her.
Welcome back.
All right.
We got it.
Oh, there's the man.
Guys, I don't know.
Try and kill one roach or should we just request that we get
the hell out of here?
I think we should just leave.
I think we should take our...
I think there's a dog roaming out.
So, so, so, how...
So, who let the dogs out?
Who was it?
Is it something?
Who was the one that let the dogs out?
It's just the ghost of my past, present, and future.
I felt like I had the ghost of the past, present, future
come to me on Christmas Day.
That day.
Be like, we let the dogs out.
We did pretty all right.
I think we did a good job.
I think we did pretty all right.
He's happy.
Look at him.
Alright, here you go.
Oh, yeah, you're like a little scratch.
Yeah.
You like that little tongue rub.
Okay.
Open cabinet.
God, we're good.
Did you throw a B at me?
We did it!
Hide no verdict!
Yay!
It's a miracle.
Oh, we did it.
Oh, because technically all of us are alive because he
resurrected us at the end.
Yeah!
We got more Nomeo.
Oh, but we lost the gloves.
Oh, my God.
Help.
All right.
You're right, though.
I'm an idiot.
Stop dropping her all.
I got a helmet.
I guess you didn't stop in the end.
Wait, we got.
Okay, we can buy another glue glove.
Okay.
How many bees do we have?
How is he surviving in this altitude?
I'm going to buy a glue glove.
Guys, I can climb anything now.
So we can climb anything.
That would be good for us.
This is we in this situation.
Out of interest.
Alright, where do you want to go?
The mountaintop or the island?
Mountaintop was terrible.
The island was also terrible.
But we shouldn't either of these are good options.
I think we should go back to the island, honestly.
I think we should go back to the island.
Alright, who still has these?
We should go back to the island quickly.
He pulls me off me.
Alright.
Back to the island we go.
Okay, up we go
Nome island all right there were there were evil i just
remembered there were evil gnomes guys It was we forgot
Break any steal any could stab a rat with a knife.
How do we pepper spray?
Oh Oh, remember that red plastic thing that?
mouse you found earlier that's the pepper spray yeah so we
gotta spray the the guy oh we're so done oh it's still a
clock yeah come here come here come here wait i can climb
anything okay i'm good at that oh and nice did i open it
push hey guys i'm spotter no oh god oh god
out he's coming out we have pepper spray right now this
would have been perfect
yeah yeah that's where he found it last time oh my god he's
coming out oh he's got oh he's got oh is she gonna burn her
oh oh my god oh he just chucked it oh oh she's dead she's
she may or may not be oh wait wait they're biting him wait
they're stinging him
um you think she's alive or no wait you're alive okay nice
we can go up now all right okay we have break he might be
following me so just be careful oh he followed me guys guys
i have the glue gloves so let's hope he doesn't throw me out
into that mountain.
I do have the glue gloves.
The glue gloves was very expensive, guys.
It was very, very expensive.
It was so expensive.
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna go this way.
I was just hoping that he would just die from all the
beasts.
Guys, he's gone.
That what?
all right give me up give me up give me up give me oh my god
i am struggling to climb my entire job is to climb and i'm
struggling right now oh
it's okay it's okay we can get one thing done on this i'm
pretty sure
all right here i go back up here i go hey guys no no no oh
no oh no he's gone he's gone he's gone nice nice save save a
knife we need a knife wait is this plastic oh this is
plastic uh break any item plastic how do you know if it's a
plastic i don't know it looks plastic i mean i don't know i
don't know no way is this plastic this might be It could be.
Oh.
What?
Oh, you're fucking armed.
Oh, it hurts.
Okay, wait.
Where's my glue glove?
My oobbs.
Don't worry.
I'm gluing.
Are you okay?
There's a rat.
Yeah, but we have to stab it.
We have to stab.
We have to stab a rat.
Where a knife is.
This is plastic.
This is also plastic.
This is glass.
We got one.
Okay, this goes outside.
I'm okay.
Okay.
We need to steal any kitchen.
Oh, wait, wait.
We have the...
This is a kitchenware.
We have to bring it out.
Because it's kitchenware.
It's kitchenware.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you bring it out.
I go try and find knife.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Glue.
Oh, my God.
A stupid mousetrap.
I'm not...
You can't get me this.
Not again.
Where the fuck are the knives?
Is there a knife in here?
I found the pepper spray!
We gotta spray that motherfucker!
Okay.
Wait.
Does this count as kitchenware?
Wait, we already...
We got one.
We got kitchenware already.
We need plastic and a clock.
We got sap.
Where is he?
Guys!
He went upstairs.
Guys, I found the pepper spray!
Get him to me!
What'd you find?
The pepper spray!
Also, where's Rin?
Did she die?
I don't know.
She would have told us she would start haunting our asses.
Where is Rin?
I think he went upstairs.
Yeah, but how am I gonna...
I feel like I'm gonna spray myself accidentally.
I'm gonna wait here.
I'll lay them down here.
Lay them down here.
I have the pepper spray locked and loaded.
all right i'm ready i'm ready oh the one time the one time i
have the pepper spray and he's not coming down all right we
have a clock yeah lead him down i have it right here we're
out of the house in the next few minutes if one of you could
resurrect me from the 15 ways i just died that'd be
wonderful thank you I'm trying!
Did I get him?
I got five bit...
Um, I don't think I got him.
You got me!
I don't think I got him.
Um...
I might not have...
He might be too tall.
Wait, wait, wait.
I got you now, buddy.
I got you now!
I got him.
Wait
They're not getting him.
Wait, where did I throw it?
Oh, guys, I didn't get
him.
Oh, I pepper sprayed myself
Get a vantage point get a vantage angle Get on the stairs.
I'm trying Okay, oh god, you got me you got me.
Okay All right, at this point wait, I think I broke him
wait, I broke the guy Wait, I broke him.
Wait, he's sunlocked.
Guys, we can finish this.
We just need to steal a clock and...
It's okay.
Leave the pepper spray here.
He's sunned.
He's sunlocked.
We gotta steal a clock.
We gotta steal a clock and stab a rat with a knife.
I don't know where a knife lives.
All right, we just gotta get those two.
Knives live in the kitchen.
No, there was no knife there.
I looked.
Really?
Yeah.
I looked everywhere.
Maybe he keeps his knife next to his bedside, just in case
for home invaders like us.
Oh, maybe.
I mean, that's smart.
Maybe it's here.
Ow.
Okay.
All right.
Maybe it's here.
Maybe he keeps it down here.
No, no knives here.
Where do they keep the knives?
Okay.
Is it like a poop knife?
Yeah, maybe it's a poop knife situation.
You know, some people keep their knives next to their
toilets.
I don't judge.
No judgment here.
There must be a clock next to them.
Was there a clock?
Oh, I see the clock!
Wait, watch this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, but watch this.
Glue gloves.
I'm a spider gnome.
i'm gonna die no i'm under the bed i'm under the bed i might
have jumped up okay don't worry i can regrow okay i'm here
okay i'm spider gnome okay all right oh look at me go that's
right spider gnome coming in
got the clock get out of here oh fuck it's okay just rest on
resting in the bed a little longer
all right yeah we got the clock maybe something here maybe
the knife is here is there a knife here oh my god i just
really like this bed i i just really like this bed
okay still need to stab a rat oh the are we gonna find a
goddamn knife in this world
oh my god there's no knives anywhere
there's no way there has to be one knife anywhere
there's an evil gnome there's an evil gnome but he can't get
me because i'm spider gnome
i i have the evil gnome distracted
oh you're down here wait oh wait that's where wait is the
gnome the evil gnome still there He's still there.
Is he spawn camping me?
Wait, there's a dog.
Guys, don't let it beat me up.
Go!
That spider.
I'm spider doping away Is he still there?
Is he camping me?
This asshole Oh my god oh my god who died that's homily got
beat up by everyone that is in youtube oh no oh no i got no
it's over it's over he's the evil gnome got me
i wanted to be a hero People know.
Yeah, he did.
Did he beat up?
Wait, did he beat you up too, Rind?
Yeah, he beat me up too.
Wait, Rind, how did you die?
I guess I'll never know.
I got beat up.
I got beat.
I couldn't fight back.
He spawned, killing me instantly.
He spawned kept me.
You know that's karma.
Because it was pretty funny.
That's dull.
We were we did our best But our best was not enough I think
we did pretty well, you know what?
I think we were gnome of the month Yeah, yeah, yeah My god,
you know, I think I think we were gnome of the month guys.
We did we were no more of us All four of us We did of your
mouth.
We did so Why are you guys so cute?
Look at his nose.
Oh my god, Amalie, you're burning.
Oh god, I'm on fire.
Oh god, oh god.
Stop dropping roll.
Oh, she did stop.
Well, I did give her CPR.
I don't know that CPR works, but bond wounds.
I'm back.
I'm back, bitches.
No.
Well, he's not letting you go.
Let me out.
He likes the taste of me.
Okay, kids, what?
Okay, kids, what did we learn today about...
I'm a home invasion.
No, man.
drop mouse traps on your tiny friends yeah good stock yeah
and go in that room disease yeah great stock don't you want
to be don't get don't go into evil gnome territory that's
their that's their hood yeah where would the evil gnome
territory i trust find the evil gnomes i don't know they
just kind of hang out outside sometimes i can't believe we
like defeated the human being and then just die to our
brethren to the evil gnomes this really says something about
society yeah what did you learn rin very little uh don't let
people drop mousetraps on you i suppose yeah but that's her
lesson that's her you know what mine's on mine's a different
angle on it what what did you learn i learned when someone's
throwing bees everyone will blame everyone else throwing b
it was you delegation of responsibility it was you you guys
blamed everybody else but me oh i learned how to kiss gnomes
guys i learned how it's okay you go up to it and be like
where it's like No, my arm!
Bye!
She did.
Oh, God.
They call me Doki, the gnome kisser.
That's a very neat...
Who's calling me that?
You know, they are.
The gnome kisser.
Yeah, they're calling me that.
Of course they.
Sorry, my mistake.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
That had fun.
GG's guys.
I know you...
That was so much fun.
you're very tired you're very tired and you're very tired
too i stayed up because i love y'all big kisses one one one
yeah maybe the real moral of the story is the power of
friendship yeah wow yeah no i can't take it i can't take it
oh yeah my arm i love ours up oh god for games yeah it's fun
yes wow i had a great time with all of you guys until next
time in this case all right yeah i have a 9 a.m convention
today yeah all right good night good night everybody go go
sleep everyone
That was fun.
I've had a great time with the girlies.
Great gnome.
I know I'm not gnelf.
I'm not a gnoblin.
We're gnoms.
And
you...
I'm honestly, I'm not that tired.
I took a nap before the collab.
So I'm not as tired as I should be.
Um...
yeah anyway guys i'm gonna call it here um tomorrow we have
an early convention to well it's like not early for it's an
east coast convention but it'll be early for me uh be an
easty convention so i think i have to be at 9 a.m um it'll
be a pattern one meeting and then we're gonna have our
record later yeah anyways i'm gonna go rest up a little bit
as always everybody say hi it posture check get up and move
that move around get that blood flowing you still for me
head to bed guys you deserve it i'll see everybody later bye
bye guys oh yeah by the way um final guest got announced
it's nimi wow the reason why i took so long was that um uh
nimi wanted nimi wanted her portion to be uh the free
portion so we had to make sure everything was finalized uh
before we It took a lot of work because I really wanted to
make this happen.
So we're going to have, for those who didn't know, we're
going to have three songs as a free stream preview on the
day of the concert.
And then so Nimi is part of the free portion.
So there's going to be like two solos and one duet.
And Nimi is part of it.
So that was the last guest announcement.
So we wanted to confirm that we could do it and that
streaming tickets will be announced very, very, very soon.
TM.
So yeah, on the day of the concert, there will be a free
streaming preview, but it will only be three songs.
It will only be three songs, and then we're going to cut it
to the, we'll have like a, there'll be a little area, like a
little streaming room where you can actually all chat about
the concert and stuff for those who aren't watching via the
stream.
So we'll leave the stream open for people who want to chat
about the stream later on too.
But yes, that's really everything.
I'm gonna see you guys later everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.